[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bien nous allons à présent puisque vous
êtes vous particulièrement très gentil
vous interprétez un petit sketch que
personnellement j'aime beaucoup par nos
camarades pas du tout parce que lui ne
l'a jamais compris pourquoi vous
permettez je vous en prie merci
je m'étonne de voir comment comment il
est pas neuf heures ah non il est 20h50
excusez moi je suis un peu en avance
c'est rien ça arrive à tout le monde
et ben voilà il est juste 9
j'aurais pas voulu faire rater leur wii
mc angers pas l'heure j'ai la tête à
l'envers jeu ce qui prouve bien qu'on
aurait tort de se faire du souci en tout
cas vous les administrent est très bien
c'est bien si vous être aujourd'hui est
ce que vous faites dans la vie des
administrateurs
en tout cas vous les gens qui s'y est
très bien je vous ai eu oui alors là je
ne vois pas vous ne voyez pas non je ne
va pas vous ne voyez je ne vois pas du
tout si vous préférez par exemple
oculiste à aux coulisses
oui je vois vous voyez je vois je vois
très bien ce sera de 1000 francs et non
c'est pas cher au réalisateur on va pas
se quitter comme ça ce serait dommage
que j'aime pas tellement
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
mais oui oui oui un peu oui appris oui
appris ah oui à temps
oui à pizza oui oui vous êtes pas
capables d'attraper une brique avec vos
mains non six patrons alors quoi mais
oui mais moi moi en plus d'attraper
bruit au travail ce n'est pas une raison
de petits bonhommes monsieur pascal en
plus attraper des briques
jamais deux dans un sceau pendant le
saut au crochet tirer sur la corde pour
un tel saut avec les white chaque fois
et alors alors je mets le dos dans le
saut
j'attrape la première riche j'ai le
temps je parle ce crochet que j'attrape
des zemmouris puis j'ai le temps c'est
quand je tire la corde
on va pas du tout alors je ne vois pas
du tout rouge katina tient la corde
pendant tout le saut et jettera permis
dans le ventre ou jascha corps pour
agrafer la brique et je dois aussi plié
commence alors je vous montrais sera
difficile pour le premier temps dans mon
logement voulons dans mon sens glou glou
glou glou à première brique gelabale
c'est vous parce que vous allez entendre
une deuxième temps j'accroche morceaux
au crochet up ville deuxième ris ne
bougeront pas attention je tire ma corde
non car accor réservés
d'accord les cheminots
oui alors dites moi comment on fait pour
faire descendre le sauve à ce qu'une
brique actuate là vous avez à présent
que vous interprétez une tranche de vie
quand j'ai dit que nous avons ramené au
cours des nombreux périples dans les
usines parisienne ça s'intitule la
chaîne g
krach rampant pippa boeing ou garmin et
qui dit qui lui permit ne craque pas
bing a good dernier kylie kylie permis
le trac patent mines pas aux young boys
qui emmenait c'est la pause à ali bongo
lieu dimanche j'ai vu une fille comme ça
il encore qui fait que les sites web
comment sait-on truc toi comment tu
pètes les foires sept constructeurs
voire anormal en bas c'est facile alors
marche
je l'appelle gracq elle arrive enfin
robert acteur salue en bouche un coin
ding je remets de la maison au winch au
portail basculant est terminée et toi
comment cet autrui comme andy pettitte
commencer ton truc
[Musique]